hello freak [ __ ] I spend my life
baffled oh that's okay I just gone I
just go with it nice good for you to be
baffled good for you it is it is it is a
good way to approach it yeah make me
happy I will tell you that it's
definitely happier than trying to
control everything yeah a lot of people
that go down that rabbit hole that's not
a good rabbit hole to go down no but I
think controlling things are it's fear
driven right sure yeah yeah definitely a
lot of it I think I'm too old to be
fearful really a wee bit yes yeah but
you are like a see there's a certain
thing that happens to people in show
business when they get to a certain age
either they feel like it's slipping away
or they feel comfortable
you seem like a comfortable person and
the comfortable person well kind of kind
of yeah what's uncomfortable I'm
uncomfortable about a lot already Joey
I'm sorry present your follower your
guard by giving you something really
beneath me first and then you live in
like and just yeah you don't even know
if I go to the lighthouse I did it and
no I'm uncomfortable about a lot of
things but I hear what you're saying and
yeah I feel like maybe if you feel like
you've failed and then you get back up
then you start your you either crumble
and you can't build your life back up or
you you find us a place to stand and you
build you're cleared again on your own
terms and then it is comfortable is that
what you're saying like that's what are
you where you're at that's what I'm
saying but you never failed
I felt I did really how yeah well you
know we haven't we in the 90s were so
much a sort of pop cultural zeitgeist I
guess right you know and that can't last
forever
but when it stops I should speak for
myself when it stopped I was it was
busying for me I don't really know what
to do with myself I didn't really
understand my identity you know I mean I
didn't know who I was arrived because it
was such a crazy right and I identified
with myself as a successful person and
my idea of success was was really warped
you know so your idea of success was
commercial success correct
yeah did you take any comfort in the
artistic success I did eventually but at
the time I felt like we were being
creatively adventurous and we were
getting punished for it and it made me
really angry um so you feel like were
you getting published I mean was it the
publishers though the music publishers
that were punishing you like what was no
it wasn't even that person although I
took it personally it was really much
more a cultural shift you know right so
it just wasn't received as well correct
you are correct sir hmm yeah and so
we've been used to being on top of the
charts you know and then when that stops
all of a sudden you're like well is
everything we're doing all our ideas
rubbish mm I'm a deep down you know
they're not but you're being rejected
anyway and so you have to find a way
through that and that's complicated I
think art was complicated for a simple
girl like me yeah well I would imagine
any time you're as big as garbage was in
the 90s me you guys were gigantic I mean
it was hard to go into a clothing store
without hearing your music blaring yeah
you know very much yeah I'm a huge fan I
love you guys thank you so it's kind of
weird sent across me I'm enjoying myself
you seem to be yeah but it's like II I
would imagine that like as big as you
guys were that you either stay that big
and then you become a crazy person you
probably better off like doing what you
did like like taking our artistic
chances settling in and then doing what
you're doing now being more comfortable
yeah okay so I mean we were lucky he had
a manager a very wise manager keeper
management at the time who said what you
want you want a long career a lower
level or do you want a short career a
ridiculously high level and we were like
we want the long career and you know
that's exactly what we got in the end
but there was this mad blip that
happened for alternative music which had
never gotten really that much pop
cultural success I guess we were like we
enjoyed this weird rush of alternative
music that for a blip ruled the charts
if you
an old band you were nothing band yeah
you guys caught that way of that post
Nova Nirvana we have yeah that's really
what it was right yeah yeah I would love
to talk to Chris Cornell like remember
when Chris Cornell did those pop music
songs like you went from Soundgarden
it's like deep crazy dark band - yeah
that's like weird poppy music yes that's
softer and I'm sure he was just trying
to figure out a way to survive like we
all do you don't and it's complicated
for anybody with a career yourself
included you know you have to like adapt
and figure out well okay where does step
- nice yeah weird I think ultimately
what you got to figure out is what do
you like yeah it's hard to do what you
like sometimes no sure because if you
don't like something but it's super
successful for exactly and you might
keep doing that it's very confusing yes
surely my goodness we're gone same here
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]